this isn't the most important story by
any means but it's really really funny
you know how Donald Trump has this
history of lying about crowd sizes the
biggest example is the inauguration of
his presidency his inauguration as
president which didn't have big
attendance and Trump claimed it was
historic then he forced his first press
secretary Sean Spicer to go out and lie
on his first day on the job and say this
was the biggest audience ever and it was
just incredible Trump has done it again
and he's continued to do these campaign
style rallies he did one earlier this
week in Nashville Tennessee and the
crowd sighs that he claimed was bigger
than the configured capacity of the
arena where they did the rally the New
York Times originally said there were a
thousand people at this rally and that
was wrong they eventually corrected it
but obviously the New York Times is
failing and fake so Donald Trump tweeted
tweeted tweeted the failing and corrupt
New York Times estimated the crowd last
night at a thousand people when in fact
it was many times that number and the
arena was rocking this is the way they
demean and disparage they are very
dishonest people who don't get me and
never did now it is true that the
original New York Times article said a
thousand it was later updated to 5,500
the Trump campaign yesterday said that
there were 8,000 people at the rally
before the rally took place at another
event Trump said there were 12,000
people already waiting for him at the
rally and eventually sort of like the
final and I guess most formal number
claimed by Trump is that there were over
8,000 people by his organization there
were over 8,000 people the problem with
that is that the capacity as laid out
for the event on Tuesday according to
Bob scone II who runs the auditorium is
that the maximum capacity was 7,500 to
8,000 so whether Trump is claiming that
there were over 8,000 people or 12,000
people it's not possible and we have a
picture by the way of the event it
really doesn't look like a huge crowd
tons of empty seats even just in this
particular area of the arena and as
usual you know I end up Pat with the
question of why bother lying about these
things Ken Trump not help himself does
he think nobody's ultimately going to
check it out
what is the fixation on such
things that from day one clearly have
fixated this guy and is it the cult of
personality is it the delusions of
grandeur the narcissism the belief that
nobody's gonna fact-check them or if
they do that he'll just call it fake
news which is what he did when people
fact-checked Sean Spicer on day one of
the administration I don't really get it
he's trying to compensate for what he
lacks I think and what he lacks right
now is high approval numbers around 40%
he also talked about the size of his
hands yet again in this campaign rally
so I think he's trying to make up for
something that he doesn't have or I mean
I'm sure he would say there's a problem
there of course that's where my mind is
going you think that these claims are
the equivalent of the guy who drives the
gigantic monster truck despite having no
practical need for it maybe as
compensation for some other physical
shortcoming that they may be
experiencing yeah that's Trump in a
nutshell I think yeah yeah that maybe
that actually maybe so once again lies
about crowd size I mean why just move on
move on to lies that are more useful to
you right because ultimately who is
really impressed by a crowd of over
8,000 or 12,000 versus 5,500 aren't
people paying attention to other things
now although maybe I'm wrong maybe like
the committed Trump is really does care
about whether there were fifty five
hundred people or eighty five hundred
people I don't know I don't really know
too many the President of the United
States you're supposed to be able to get
a large crowd to attend your rallies
wouldn't you think I mean ten thousand
even drawing those numbers that should
be easy for him didn't sixty million
vote for the guy like really what
difference does it make whether eighty
five hundred or twelve thousand or five
thousand people went to one one
particular rally